a plasma ball watch it gets your camper
out of the water oh it's supposed to go
in the water
okay Vsauce Kevin here this is my flow
this Mario in a box game works by
controlling a knob on the side of the
box and if you hit an enemy a magnetic
sensor triggers the box to close ending
the game the level scrolls on a wheel
and it was built by League Labs find the
link below on how to make and where to
buy one if iPad gaming with an
old-school flares more your style
there's this new Atari arcade doc it's a
sleeker and more affordable alternative
to the I cake exploding crossbow a
weapon that's less explodey and more
puzzly as the Jenga pistol the pistol
was laser-cut from 5 millimeter acrylic
and was inspired by this wooden one made
a couple years ago you can actually find
the instructables link below the world's
largest ever balloon fight took place at
the University of Kentucky and involved
8950 7 people and 170 5141 water
balloons and if they did it at Cornell
University they could have eaten some
delicious printed food afterwards taking
a scientific approach to food they
basically filled syringes with various
flavors and textures and then used a
printer and software to print out the
simulated food ok a simulated Star
Destroyer was recently created out of
over 43,000 Legos no glue or support
structures were used just the lot of
Legos for Star Wars origami battle
there's this new ad from moleskin
notebooks
ok look at this picture do you see the
green and blue swirls well that's
interesting because they're actually the
same color let's pull this picture into
Photoshop if you don't believe it
see these colors only appear different
because of the effects of the
surrounding colors on our arm
my go BASE jumping has never looked more
epic than in this video with footage
from Norway Switzerland and France
finally here's one guys epic recreation
of the Jonny Quest opening
and I'm gonna leave you with the $5 bill
stack of pancakes
there are four clues in the description
of this video the first person to get
all four correctly will be our genius of
the week so good luck and as always
thanks for watching